A 14-time All-Star,...
...five-time Gold Glove Award winner,...
...five-time Silver Slugger Award winner,...
...the first player to win the All-Star Game MVP and World Series MVP...
...in the same season,...
...Derek is a five-time world champion...
...and the face of the Yankees franchise for almost 20 years.
I've had the greatest job in the world.
I got a chance to be the shortstop for the New York Yankees...
...and there's only one of those.
And I always felt as though that my job...
...was to try to provide joy and entertainment for you guys,...
...but it can't compare to what you brought me.
So, for that, thank you very much.
I've loved what I've done.
I loved what I do.
More importantly, I've loved doing it for you.
So, from the bottom of my heart, thank you very much.